meantime metro police shot and killed a
person on the east side of the valley
they report it happened just this
morning near Charleston and lamb Joshua
peguero has the latest now from Metro
Police
there is still a lot of police at the
scene I'm a step out of the way so you
can take a look at where police have
blocked off a specific vehicle that was
evolved in the incident Metro Police say
this started with the road rage incident
at around 11 this morning at Nellis and
Bonanza a person pulled out a gun at
another driver police found that person
who was said to have the gun tried to
pull them over but the driver took off
police initiated a vehicle Pursuit
ending in a neighborhood near Colusa
Circle in Sacramento Drive officers then
fired into the vehicle killing the
driver but didn't say whether that
person threatened police or showed a
weapon the witness I spoke to when we
first arrived said police shot a woman
my mom said she saw them shoot the lady
in the red car
the shots were at her police have not
released to us if it is a man or a woman
no one else was hurt in this scene as
you can see behind me is still very
active and we don't know yet when police
were in their investigation reporting
near Charleston and lamb Joshua berguero
eight news now